[Musique]
à la veille de la séance plénière du 22
juin le président du département cyrille
melchior a convié la presse pour
présenter le premier bilan des six mois
de mise en oeuvre du plan de mandature
en présence des élus béatrice sigismeau
jeannick atchapa augustine romano et
églantine victorine il a tenu à revenir
sur l'évolution de l'offre d'accueil à
destination des publics vulnérables
prévu à l'ordre du jour de ladite séance
plénière a alors après nord le
renouvellement du conseil départemental
j'ai souhaité faire un point sur le plan
de mandature que nous avons élaboré et
adopté ensemble unanimement et ce plan
de mandature bas consacre un certain
nombre de projets d'ambition notamment
pour les publics les plus vulnérables
nous avons notamment que les personnes
âgées personnes handicapées et bien
déployer un plan visant à mettre en
place plusieurs projets structurant pour
le territoire avec cinq ehpad à
construire pour les prochaines années
donc 500 places de plus en hébergement
voit les personnes âgées ouais 2 300
places supplémentaires pourquoi les
personnes porteuses de handicap et nous
sommes en train de construire un nouvel
établissement d'accueil pour les enfants
à salue notamment ce qui veut dire que
nous offrons beaucoup plus de places
d'accueil pour les personnes en
difficulté et nous travaillons si au
niveau des violences intrafamiliales
avec 13 travailleurs sociaux dans les
casernes de gendarmerie ou les
commissariats de police pour favoriser
l'accueil des victimes de violences
intrafamiliales
le président a cité d'autres mesures
phares mises en oeuvre dans le cadre des
10 ans missions portées par le conseil
départemental
nous voulons aussi réhabiliter les
logements puisque passant de 2000 à 4000
logements réhabilités c'est un plan
ambitieux que nous portons pour la
rénovation donc des logements ici à la
réunion sur la partie aménagement du
territoire donc on le voit bien donc
tout ce qui est l'investissement le
département est très présent nous
travaillons aussi sur la pratique
économiques notamment sur la partie
rurale avec les thermes de cilaos qui
vont être réhabilités qui sont en cours
de réhabilitation
et puis on le sait aussi donc
l'agriculture
donc nous sommes très présents avec le
volet développement agricole le plan
agrippé 2020-2030 irrigation des terres
l'aide à la production et à la
diversification
l'accompagnement des agriculteurs qui
ont été victime de cyclones bassu à tous
ces coins là nous sommes très présents
la bonne tenue des comptes du
département a également été abordée à
travers les grandes lignes des rapports
financiers l'occasion de réaffirmer une
situation financière satisfaisante en ce
début de mandature
[Musique]